hey guys today is another video request
some of you asked me daniel please make
a video on how to be more productive
and motivated in life how do you do it
how do you
run two youtube channels and have time
for everything else
in your life well first you need to
understand
that there is a huge difference between
just being busy
with things and getting things done
so in this video i'm gonna tell you how
to be more productive and motivated
to get things done and achieve your
goals
let's get to it
[Music]
now just very quick if it's the first
time that you're on my channel my name
is daniel
and welcome to dlm men's lifestyle if
you haven't subscribed yet please
consider it
and also click that notification bell so
you won't miss any of the next
videos and even if you're a woman you're
also welcome to my channel
now there are seven main things that
help me
to be more productive and motivated in
life
let's start with the first thing
[Music]
number one stop making excuses
and be honest look you can't change
if you're not brutally honest with
yourself first
a lot of guys out there they make
excuses they never take responsibility
for their own decisions and actions
so they blame it on other people in
other situations instead of owning it
like a man i heard this quote somewhere
it is only when you take responsibility
for your life that you discover how
powerful
you truly are look at your life
seriously
be honest with yourself and own all
those
bad habits all those mistakes that
you've done don't blame it on other
people
own it all those things that make you
lazy unproductive and unmotivated
and you got to understand is not the end
of the world
if you make mistakes we all make
mistakes no one is perfect
actually that's where you learn in life
the most
where you learn from your mistakes you
grow from it
that's how you improve as a person this
is where you start to take control
of your life and change the direction of
your future
be honest with yourself and take
responsibility for your own
decisions stop making excuses
jim ron said if you really want to do
something you'll find a way to do it
if you don't you'll find excuses
set your goals what are your goals in
life what are your short-term goals
medium-term
goals and long-term goals think about it
if you don't have any it's time to sit
down and to create some and write them
down
on paper with a timeline if you have a
goal with no timeline
and with no plan it's just gonna stay a
dream
cs lewis said you are never too old to
set another goal
or to dream a new dream now i'll just
add in that you're not too young
either start and learn from a young age
to
work hard for your own future
listen you can't be motivated and driven
to achieve something if you don't have a
goal
you got to start today don't wait for
tomorrow
i have a lot of goals in life and they
drive me every single day
to work hard and smart to achieve them
and here's the interesting part it's not
the goal itself that changes you
is the journey towards that goal that
changes you
so enjoy the journey as well
get into a good routine if you can
manage to create a good routine for
yourself that fits in with your
lifestyle
and that leads you to your goals then
that
that will change your life why because
your routine will change your habits and
good habits will bring you
success brian tracy said successful
people
are simply those with successful habits
ask yourself this question and be honest
remember brutally honest
what does your daily routine look like
right now
and where is it leading you in life
listen
if you want to achieve your goals but
you don't work for them
every day is not going to happen your
goals
are just going to stay a dream your life
won't change
if you don't change what you do daily
[Music]
prioritize everything every day
look if you don't prioritize things
you'll just stay busy
you won't get things done time is
precious
so don't waste it you know there are a
lot of people who just stay
busy with things they waste their time
they take a lot longer to do certain
things daily things
they waste their time doing nothing and
that changes
everything let me give you some examples
they talk
too much to other people while working
or they take their time to walk or to
drive from a to b
or they shower for 25 minutes
instead of just 10. now these are normal
things but that is just the point
is the normal things that people do that
changes
everything the way they do it if you
want to finish a day successfully
by completing your list of priorities
then
you just need to stop wasting time is
that simple
then very important don't prioritize
things that are not
a priority for you think about your life
your goals and what you need to do to
achieve them
and then schedule your priorities and
here comes the important part
you need to be willing to sacrifice
certain
things if you want to achieve your main
priorities in life there are always
other things
that are less important that you will
need to sacrifice
[Music]
work hard and rest hard you know some
people say work hard and play hard
but i would rather rest hard to just get
my batteries
back to recharge and then after that
then
i can also play i'll have to do things
like catching fish and
go sand boarding or something else you
know there are some people that
when they go on holiday they plan a
super busy
schedule full of events and then when
they come back
they're still tired no you need to rest
and then you need to feel this need
inside of you to start working again
then you'll know you've rested enough
did you know that a field that has
rested longer
yields a better crop it's true and it's
true for us humans as well
you will get a lot more things done when
you are refreshed
rested when you're full of energy
compared to
working too hard and being burned out be
careful
because if you don't take breaks and if
you overwork yourself
you will start to lose focus and
motivation not only that
it might even influence your health i
learned this the hard way
i got sick a few times because i just
burned out
busy with the channels busy preparing uh
getting the videos ready editing
managing some of the team members and it
just drained me but i still went on and
i worked
and i just burned out and i got sick a
few times
so remember yes work hard but also
rest hard
[Music]
connect with like-minded people you know
the worst thing you can do is to hang
out with people that are lazy
who don't have any direction in life or
who don't care about their own
future you gotta pick the right friends
friends who inspire you
not drain you or bring you down iron
sharpers iron
and one man sharpens another this was
written more than 2 000 years ago
and it is still true today you know
you gotta hang around with those kind of
people
that force you to level up and those who
don't
those who don't support you well don't
be angry at them
just ignore what they say love them and
then show them
what you can do you know even some of my
friends and family didn't believe
in me when i wanted to start youtube
they thought
daniel it's just a waste of time you
won't be able to achieve
success but i didn't let them bring me
down
i knew what i was capable of doing and i
did it
listen you need to know yourself but
also
don't limit yourself either
[Music]
faith the last thing i'm mentioning to
you is the most important
to me you ask me right how do i do it
how do i stay
motivated and productive well the
biggest thing
that makes me productive that makes me
stay motivated
and it gives me direction purpose
passion and joy is my faith
in god i definitely agree with c.s lewis
he said i believe in christianity as i
believe that the sun
has risen not only because i see it
but because by it i see everything
else i wasn't always a reborn christian
but when i became one it changed my
whole
life if you want to know my story of how
it happened how it changed me
then you can watch it here on my other
channel and i'll see you there
and always remember this life is short
so don't waste yours cheers guys